and you're going to hear a lot of
demagogues
on both sides of the aisle prattling on
about this upsetting of norms and we've
never seen this before
and when i say demagogue by the way i
think a lot of people think i'm
referring to
donald trump because he's got these some
of these characteristics
i'm talking about guys like mitt romney
too i'm talking about these
preening moral cynics
who one day go out and march with the
people who torch cities and commit
political violence
and then the next day shake their heads
and wring their hands
we've never seen anything like this
trump is so terrible i'm the dignified
mitt romney give me
a break you're going to see this a lot
but
you're going to hear joe biden say this
is not who we are well it kind of looks
like it's who we are right now
and i hope we cool it hope we
take it down hope we like our countrymen
again
but right now it doesn't appear to be
this way and we've gone through periods
like this before
happened in the 1960s i was not alive in
the 1960s was barely a glint in my
father's eye
however they killed the president
the president was assassinated in the
60s then they killed his brother
when he was running for president
then they killed the major civil rights
leader
there was violence in the street there
was there were domestic terror groups
like the weather underground
radical left-wing group that set off
bombs
that committed acts of domestic terror
that was not that long ago
was that 60 years ago
before that people everyone at least
remembers the 60s i guess
before that though we went through
periods in the 19 teens 1920s
when you had anarchists in the streets
communists in the street too
setting off bombs engaging in political
violence
the one sort of couple of the names that
you might hear in school is sacco and
vanzetti
these italian guys who were committing
political violence in the country
but but there were other other sorts of
attacks like this
happened before that too 1912 there was
an attempted assassination
of our president president teddy
roosevelt
1901 you had an assassination
in the 1880s you had a presidential
assassination
in the 1860s you had a presidential
assassination
obviously that was that presidential
assassination was only at the end
of apparently a very bad play but also a
five-year civil war
constant political violence and
bloodshed for five years how many people
seven hundred
thousand americans died if you include
the confederate and the union soldiers
together
there has there has been political
violence and there could be political
violence again
and i think we have just because we're
so freaking decadent
because we are so bored
because we are so frivolous
as a matter of culture and society we
convince ourselves that can't happen
nah that's not a big deal i don't worry
come on it's america
that's sort of this sort of stuff
doesn't happen we're a young country
we're a young country that's had a lot
of political violence in his past
anything could happen and i i just i
wish
i wish that the people who stormed the
capital for their own sake would have
just thought through this a little bit
and said
what's the end of this if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
[Music]
you